All right, let's go.
2012, DeLibor from the Czech Republic.
Good luck, DeLibor.
And we have another Sicilian and we
have faced virtually no open Sicilians.
This is, this is a plague on humanity.
Everybody's going night C3 now.
It's crazy.
And we've already faced this move like
three or four times, but hey, this is a
realistic cross section of what people
play nowadays.
Opening fashions change.
I feel like even like two, three years
ago, open Sicilian was, you know,
everybody was playing it and the people
who weren't were playing the Aleppan.
Now people are going for all sorts of
night C3 variations.
We're going to respond with a move that
I talked about previously, rather than
going night C6.
And the downside of night C6 is that it
allows this incredibly tricky sideline,
Bishop B5.
We've already faced this sideline.
I've gotten into trouble against it.
And around that time, I talked about
the immediate G6, which is very
uncommon, but it sidesteps a lot of
annoying lines.
If white is a grand pre -attack player,
then it doesn't really matter what you play.
You can play night C6 or G6.
Our opponent is a grand pre -attack
player, which is night C3 followed by F4.
The grand pre -attack is one of the most
dangerous systems against the Sicilian.
I haven't refreshed my own theory in a
long time.
So this is going to be really fun.
Let's see if we can avoid getting checkmated.
First things first.
Let's fianchetto our Bishop.
And usually white plays night F3.
And in this position, we have several
different setups.
Essentially, we can start by playing
D6, or we can start with a more
conventional night to C6.
Let's play more conventionally with
night C6.
And Bishop C4 is the old school move.
The new school move is Bishop to B5.
This is a more positional way of
playing the grand pre -attack.
Bishop C4 is the sort of old school
method where you're aiming directly at F7.
And you can watch my previous videos
for more of a background on the grand
pre -attack, because this is a higher
level game.
I'm going to skip straight to the sort
of juice and talk about the moves themselves.
Afterward, we'll do a little bit more
theoretical investigating.
Okay.
So as far as I know, the most popular
setup, and this was popularized many
decades ago, is what was taught to me
as the Botvinnik setup.
And that is where you go E6, and then
you'd put the knight on E7.
It's essentially like Fianchetto,
knight on E7, knight on C6, and you can
do it with white as well.
This is a setup, this is a system, not
necessarily a specific setup against a
particular opening.
E6, as far as I remember, there's this
very dangerous gambit line where white
responds with D4.
So there's a lot of theory associated
with the move E6.
And because I haven't refreshed my
knowledge in a long time, I'm inclined
to play a slightly more modest move.
Maybe we can start with D6, and then we
can either play E6 or we can play a
line that I introduced a couple of
speedrun games ago, where we bring our
knight actually out to H6.
This is an also interesting line
against the grand pre -attack.
Let me think about what we want to do here.
So E6, I don't really want to play, but
we can.
We can start with D6 and then play E6.
That's totally possible.
Let's do that.
Let's start with D6.
And now that we have opened up our
bishop, one thing that we don't want to
do here is play Bishop G4.
This is a terrible move that walks
right into this very well -known tactic.
Bishop takes F7 check, followed by
Knight G5.
So definitely not Bishop G4.
We can play Knight F6, but it was
taught to me a very long time ago that
you want to avoid bringing your knight
out to F6 in the grand pre -attack and
in the closed Sicilian, I'll talk a
little bit more about that after the
game, I think E6 is a much safer
option, and it's an option that makes
it more difficult for white to
jumpstart his Kingside attack.
So let's, let's go E6, Knight H6 maybe
is a move here, but with the bishop
already out on C4, there's also by the
way, the move Knight A5.
I've seen this move played sometimes
Knight A5 in order to kick the bishop
away from this diagonal.
So it should make logical sense that
you want, you would want to do that
because F7 is our weakest pawn, but
let's go E6.
Let's, let's play more conventionally
in this game.
I'm definitely out theoried.
Okay.
D4, this is a, this is getting a little
disturbing because D4 here, I'm not too
familiar with.
So basically I'm on my own and this is
where I might get crushed if I do.
Okay.
But we're going to try to use general
opening principles to figure out our
way out of this opening.
Okay.
So the idea of D4 is to blast open the center.
And as far as I remember, after C takes
D4, White responds with Knight to B5.
Uh, this is a very dangerous line and
we could get in trouble here.
After CD4, White plays Knight B5 and
then White is exerting pressure on D6.
But the main idea is that if we respond
to the move like A6, White takes the
pawn on D4.
Okay.
And once the D file is opened, the D6
pawn is quite a bit weaker.
It's easier to attack.
Now, I don't think we have much of a
choice here.
We have to take this pawn.
Maybe we could also take it with the
Knight, but I don't really see a reason
to give up our well -developed Knight.
I think we should start with C takes D4
and now we should invest a little bit
of time.
So one thing that I really don't want
to do is play A6 because what is
White's next move likely to be?
Well, likely it's going to be Knight
takes D4 anyway.
So I think A6 is, I wouldn't say a
waste of time entirely, but I would
prefer to invest the tempo that we have
into a developing move.
And there's only one logical developing move.
The reason we played E6 is in order to
pave the way for Knight G to E7.
And I think that that's what we should do.
Let's go Knight G E7.
Obviously our opponent's still in theory.
So I don't like facing prep that's this
extensive Bishop B3.
Okay.
I understand why he did this though.
The point of Bishop B3 is to take the
sting out of the move D5, which we were
sort of threatening.
Now D5 can be met with E5.
Of course the Bishop is no longer hanging.
And I don't want to play D5 E5 because
that creates big dark square holes,
both in the center and on the King side.
I don't love D5.
It's a move that we would play if we
were desperate.
I think that we can essentially
continue developing.
So I don't see a compelling reason that
we shouldn't castle King side.
I mean, again, we could play A6, but I
don't really see the reason to do that.
Yeah.
I think we should just castle.
And let's see how white responds.
And this is very extensive preparation
by our opponents.
So big, big kudos.
Okay.
So now we have a position that I know a
little bit better because this is
essentially an open Sicilian type structure.
You can compare this to an accelerated drag.
And the biggest difference is that here
our Knight is on E7.
Here we have a pawn on E6 and both of
those things don't occur that often in
the accelerated.
But by and large, in terms of the
structure in the center and the fact
that D4 has been played, we have a more
similar type of position to the open Sicilian.
Now, how are we going to proceed?
Okay.
Well, first of all, we have the option
to trade Knights, which could be good.
Could be bad.
It's hard to say.
So we could trade and then bring the
other Knight out to C6.
Very typical idea in a lot of different
Sicilian structures.
That's one option.
Another option is to basically play it
more slowly, but I'm worried that white
will play F5.
I'm really worried about this move F5,
which could really cause problems on
our King side.
So there is Queen B6.
There is Queen B6, but then white plays
Bishop E3 and our Queen really looks
dumb on B6.
Another move that we could turn to is
Knight to A5.
Maybe it's a good time to play Knight
A5 and get rid of this Bishop in order
to take the sting out of the move F5,
which otherwise could be really,
really, really scary.
So I actually kind of like the look of
Knight A5.
Yeah, let's try Knight A5.
And hopefully this will finally take
our opponent out of theory.
What I like about Knight A5 is it
doesn't, it's not a very committal move.
So we can chill on A5 as long as we
need to.
And then at the right moment, we could
take the Bishop on B3.
Obviously like Bishop A4 is a super
awkward move and that Bishop could be
targeted with A6 B5.
So I'm not worried that white's going
to keep the Bishop.
I'm not really worried about Knight B5.
That would be a really bad move because
of Queen B6 check.
It would send the Knight back to D4
where we could pick it off with the
move E5.
So I'm anticipating a developing move
like Bishop E3, and then we can breathe
a little bit easier because I know I
won't get checkmated.
No, Alan Phillip, Queen B6 and E5 would
not have worked because there was this
move Knight D4 to F5, classic trick.
I'll show that after the game.
I'll write it down actually.
Okay.
So what is going to be our kind of
system of development?
Well, when I look at this position, the
Bishop on C8 really needs to be deployed.
And I think the best spot to deploy it
is to B7, right?
I mean, we could go Bishop to D7, but
then our pawn on D6 gets even weaker.
And I feel like if we could bring our
Bishop to B7, at least we're exerting
some pressure on white's center.
So here I would not rush with Knight
takes B3 because we could play this move.
Whenever we want to.
And of course, Knight takes B3 creates
a positional concession.
It opens up the A file.
So white will be able to develop some
pressure on our Queen side.
So I think that we should go on with B6
and prepare to complete our development.
C4.
Okay.
So C4, our opponent starts playing this
very positionally, but he's really
extending himself pretty far in the
center and on the Queen side.
This pawn could end up as a weakness.
So we could play Bishop B7 here.
That would be the standard move.
Another move that's on my radar is
Bishop to A6.
I mean, if he put a pawn on C4, we
might as well try to attack it with
Bishop A6.
And we also put the Knight on A5.
So it would really justify the
placement of our pieces.
Bishop B7, I like because he can't play
Bishop C2 to defend the pawn.
C4 will hang.
So Bishop B7, probably he's going to
bring the Queen up to D3.
And then we could, for example, play
Rook C8, you know, we could play this
more normally.
But Bishop A6 looks spicy.
I really want to grab.
Whoa.
Okay.
Now our opponent has started to just
pre -move.
If this is still preparation, I would
be absolutely shocked.
Okay.
Let me think about this.
This is a dangerous move.
I, I forgot that F5 is a thing now that
we moved our Bishop away from C8.
So what do we do here?
We could grab the pawn on C4.
We could definitely grab this pawn.
That would attack the Bishop.
So White would have to respond to that.
And if White would take our Knight,
then we would take White's Bishop.
We would be attacking the Rook on F1.
And once the Rook moved, we could play
something like E5 in order to close
down the center and go after White's F5 pawn.
So I don't see a compelling reason that
we can't take on C4.
F takes E6 would block, would blunder
the Bishop on E3 with a fork.
That doesn't seem dangerous.
I'm going to call White's bluff.
I, I, oh, maybe Bishop G5 actually.
Wait a second.
Bishop G5 might be annoying because
that threatens pawn F6.
Wait, wait, wait.
Bishop G5 is a, is a problem there.
So let's think about this.
Takes Bishop G5.
We could play H6 there, but then
there's Knight C6.
No, no.
This is, this is bad.
So maybe we should play the immediate E5.
Maybe we should play the immediate E5.
But then there's still Bishop G5.
Amazing.
Okay.
Bishop takes C4.
Same problem.
I just have to think about this for a
little while.
Okay.
Let's go E5.
Let's go E5 and try to kick the Knight
out of D4.
If the Knight moves back, then I'll be
really happy because then we can just
take on F5 and of course our King side
is compromised, but it's not that easy
for White to checkmate us here with the
Bishop sitting on G7 and our pieces
clustered around the center, I think
we'll be fine.
Knight B5.
Okay.
G takes F5 maybe.
I don't want to take this Knight and
open up the diagonal for White's Bishop.
We can do that whenever we want to.
So G takes F5, Knight takes D6 is
chaotic, but chaotic is good.
We want chaotic here.
Okay.
Let's play GF.
Let's play GF for now because
otherwise, you know, that pawn on F5 is
a huge problem for us.
And we're down to six minutes.
Our opponent with over 15 minutes left.
This is incredible.
Very, very deep knowledge of this
opening by White.
Yeah.
I don't know exactly what we're going
to do if he takes on D6.
This is just a very hard position to
wrap our heads around and don't feel
like it's easy for me to wrap my head
around it.
It's just chaotic.
So basically in such positions, the
first person to blunder loses.
We're just going to try to avoid
blundering and play logical moves.
Yeah.
Finally, our opponent is out of prep,
which is good.
I mean, we're almost made it here, but
that's okay.
We'll survive.
We will survive.
Cue the Gloria Gaynor song.
Okay.
So what, what are we expecting here?
Well, there's, there's many ways for
White to play.
In the Grand Prix attack,
traditionally, the way that you're
recommended to meet G takes F5 is by
trying to stick the Queen on H5.
So from that perspective, Knight G5 may
seem terrifying, but it wasn't.
I don't think it was.
Knight takes D6.
All right.
So what I, what I like here is the move F4.
I think that we should try to dry up
the King side as much as possible,
because that's going to buy us a little
bit of time that we could use to kind
of untangle and coordinate our pieces a
little bit better.
So, so to me, F4 is a bit of a no
brainer because we hit the Bishop.
We create a little bit of a defensive,
a defensive, you know, bulwark on the
King side that'll make it harder for
White to infiltrate.
And we buy ourselves a tempo.
And White was obviously threatening in
this position to play E takes F5.
That is a pawn that we did not want to
give up because that's a pawn which
protects our King.
So let's start with F4.
And after the Bishop moves away, after
the Bishop moves away, we have to
decide how to address the problem of
this Knight on D6, which is right in my grill.
It's pissing me off.
This Knight is pissing me off.
I want to address this Knight.
Now we have two fundamental ways that
we can try to get rid of this Knight.
We could try to trade it, or we could
try to hit it with our pieces.
And if we want to hit it with our
pieces, the best way I think to do that
is to try to get a Rook to D8 because
the Queen alone is not exerting
sufficient pressure.
So after Bishop F2, which I'm
expecting, we could consider a move
like Queen to C7 in order to get the
Rook to D8.
Okay.
That's a reasonable move.
It also puts more pressure on the C4 pawn.
Yeah.
The downside of playing Queen C7 is
that the Knight could return to B5 with
tempo and hit the Queen.
But then we've accomplished our aim and
the Queen could tuck itself away on,
let's say B7 maybe, and then we could
bring our Rook to D8 anyway and start
getting our pieces into the game.
Another thing I would point out, a move
that I really would like to play at
some point is Knight E7 to G6, just as
a, you know, just as a way to solidify
the E5 pawn and to, you know, bring a
little bit more beef to the King side.
But I don't want to play this move when
the Knight is still sitting on D6.
And the reason why is I don't want to
give away the outpost on F5 for White's Knight.
That is a very nasty outpost in most
positions, this one included.
So Knight G6 is, I'm making a mental
note to myself to make that move a
little bit later when the smoke clears.
But right now we're going to keep our
Knight on E7 to protect the F5 square
and to protect the D5 square against,
you know, a move like Queen to D5 and
stuff like that.
By the way, if, if after Bishop F2, we
wanted to trade the Knight on D6, we
could do that with this retreating
move, Knight A5 to B7, which is not a
move that I would really discount easily.
Knight B7 is a good positional move.
We're getting rid of our opponent's
strongest piece.
In the event of the trade, our Bishop
moves back to B7 and puts pressure on E4.
I like that.
After Knight to B7, White could decline
the trade by dropping his Knight back
to B5.
Then our Knight on B7 is a little bit
awkward, but maybe we could bring it
around to C5.
So that's another option that we could explore.
A lot of you are asking about Knight G5 here.
I, I'm skeptical about Knight G5
because I don't see what it does.
After Knight G5, I feel like we could
even just play H6 and in that position,
maybe you're scared of Queen H5, but I
think we could just take the Knight on G5.
The big problem for White is that he
doesn't have the services of his Bishop.
If there was no pawn on E4, then the
Bishop could move back to C2 and exert
serious pressure on H7.
I feel like the Queen and the Knight
alone just aren't fast enough.
Also, we've taken the Rook largely out
of commission by building up this pawn chain.
So Knight G5, we might face, but I, I'm
not too scared of it and I'm scared of
most things, so I don't think this is
going to work.
Yeah, of course, after H6, White could
play Knight takes F7 and then we would
play Rook takes F7, Knight takes F7.
We might even snap the Queens off the
board and then we would recapture the
Knight on F7 and we would have, what
would we have?
We would have two pieces for the Rook
and our minor pieces are quite well placed.
Like our pieces on A5 and A6 are doing
a job, right?
They're attacking C4, so I'm fine with
an end game here.
I'm, I'm fine with the Queens getting
off the board.
Our pieces are not poorly placed.
Well, because if White ever plays C5,
then we could take on B3.
Remember that, right?
That's why we put our Knight on A5 to,
to really take the sting out of a move
like C5.
He disconnected.
I don't think so.
I think our opponent is just thinking.
There's a lot to think about here.
There's a lot to think about here for White.
I would play Bishop F2 pretty quickly.
Knight E5.
I saw this move.
I knew that this existed.
I wasn't taking it very seriously.
Maybe I should have.
So let's, let's try to deconstruct this move.
What, what on earth is happening here?
What on earth is happening here?
So two pieces are hanging.
That's the way I see it.
There's the Bishop on E3 and there's
the Knight on E5.
Either of them can be captured.
We could also take on B3, but forget
about, forget about that for now.
My intuition, and probably yours is the
same, tells me to take on E5 because
that's the problem piece, but let's
actually try to calculate.
If we instead take on E3, I would
imagine that White's idea is to play
Knight takes F7.
Okay.
What if we just move our Queen there?
What's the big whoop?
I guess the big whoop is that White
plays C5 and opens up a line of fire
toward our King.
And if we take on B3, then White takes
back with a Queen and is threatening
all sorts of shenanigans.
Okay.
Let's think about this a little bit more.
F, E, Knight takes F7.
We could play Rook takes F7.
Rook takes F7, and in that position,
might be able to throw in the move, E2.
Okay.
I need to think about this carefully
because I think I've understood his
idea after Bishop takes E5, which I
think is just to play Bishop takes F4.
But that's not too scary.
Bishop takes E5.
Another thing to remember is that if
White delivers a check on G4, how
should we deal with that check?
Well, we shouldn't bring our King into
the corner because then it could get
checkmated potentially with Knight
takes F7.
I think that Bishop E5, Queen G4, the
beauty of this Knight on E7 is that it
could block any check with Knight to G6.
So I'm going to play this move largely
on the basis of intuition, but I
calculated F takes E3 just enough to
understand that the resulting position
is extremely chaotic and hard to evaluate.
Generally, you want to avoid such
positions if you have a choice.
Sometimes you don't have a choice and
sometimes you're on the losing side.
And if you're on the losing side,
that's exactly what you want.
You want to create chaos.
Here, it's a little bit easier to
assess the position.
Our King is pretty safe.
Bishop takes F4, I think is the best move.
So first of all, we can trade Queens.
If we want to, we could play Queen
takes D6 here.
Okay.
Then White would have to take,
otherwise he's two minors down.
Bishop D6, Bishop D6.
But obviously that resulting position
is not over.
White has two pawns for the piece.
Our pieces are kind of discombobulated.
I think that we are winning after Rook F8.
I think technically that position is
probably going to be a win, but I'd
like to find something better if at all possible.
The alternative I think is to take on F4.
The Rook recaptures and we play a move
like Knight to G6 to start, you know,
to start getting our pieces to better squares.
I'm apprehensive though about leaving
the Queens on the board, especially
given our time situation.
So from the perspective of playing like
a Russian schoolboy, Queen takes D6
makes sense.
From the perspective of trying to be as
accurate as possible, I think probably
it'll end up that Bishop takes F4 is
the best move.
But again, I'm trying to give you a
realistic portrayal of what I actually
would play and what I actually would
play in a real game, given the time
situation is Queen takes D6.
It's not a glamorous move.
We're just not going to win us any
beauty prizes.
But what I know is that it gets into an
end game where we are up a minor piece
and White has no clear attack against
our King anymore.
And clearly I think this move was
missed by our opponent.
No, I take Bishop takes B2.
Why?
Right?
Why would you need this, this
meaningless pawn and give White a tempo
for an attack?
I'm sure the engine would probably
claim that Black is still winning after
Bishop takes B2.
Maybe even we could drop our Bishop
back to G7.
That's a move that wasn't on my radar
at all, but probably should have been.
Bishop G7.
Just simple.
Bring the Bishop back, keep an
important defender and just ask White
what on earth you have.
And the answer is basically nothing.
But Queen takes D6 is, you know, really
the simplifying move.
White has to take because Queen G4
check here is completely innocuous.
We just go Knight G6 and the attack is over.
Bishop takes E5, we play Queen takes E5.
We're two minor pieces up.
So nothing to think about here for our opponent.
I don't know what he's, what he's going
on about here, but Queen D6, Bishop D6,
Bishop D6 is pinning our Knight.
So how should we defend against this pin?
How should we defend against this pin?
And there is a very important tactical
detail that I calculated, which I
haven't told you guys about yet.
So how should we, how should we play this?
Well, the move is self -evident, right?
We want to not just defend the Knight,
but we also want to solve the
underlying problem of the pin.
So Rook F to E8 is basically automatic.
Now in such situations, and we
encountered a very similar position.
Yeah, that is the move that I saw.
I had to see this move when I was
calculating Queen takes D6.
We did something very similar in a
speedrun game a couple of games ago.
I'll show you after the game, Bishop A4
is scary because it hits the Rook.
We can't move the Rook because we
dropped the Knight on E7.
So you might say, well, then I have to
block on C6, but if we play Knight E
C6, well, you can see how awkward that is.
And maybe White has the move B4, but
instead we have a tactic.
And how do you find this tactic?
Well, what is the drawback of the move
Bishop A4?
Does it actually release White's
control over anything?
Yes.
There's the C4 pawn, and you should see
the possibility of Knight takes C4 as
an interesting possibility, even though
you don't, it's hard to calculate.
So Knight takes C4.
If White moves the Bishop from D6, then
we can intercept White's Bishop with B5.
Okay.
But if after Knight takes C4, White
takes the Rook, which Bishop do you take?
And that's an easy question, right?
Comparison should tell you that the
Bishop on D6 is the one that you want
to take because in that resulting
position, you're attacking the Rook and
you're attacking the Bishop on E8.
White can't save both at the same time.
We're going to end up in a position
where we have three minor pieces
against a Rook.
Now, three minor pieces against a Queen
is double -sided.
Three minor pieces against a Rook in
most cases is an overwhelming amount of
material for the minor pieces, even in
an endgame where the Rooks often benefit.
Even in an endgame where the Rooks
often benefit.
Okay.
So this is winning for Black.
Bishop takes C4, I didn't like as much.
Bishop takes C4, maybe works.
Actually, maybe we can squeak by with
that move, but I didn't like it.
And I'll show you after the game.
So Knight takes C4 was a critical
detail missed by our opponent.
Bishop takes E8, Knight takes D6.
And another important detail is that F7
is protected by our Knight.
So Bishop takes F7 check would have
released the Bishop from our clutches,
but we just take it with our Knight.
In fact, I would do that with White.
I think that's the only way that he can
get, you know, a Pawn for the piece.
But then we have three minor pieces for
a Rook and two Pawns, which is not over.
Right?
The game is not over there.
We would have to demonstrate some
technique, but I think Black is winning.
What if Bishop B4?
Well, then B5.
Toxic at the end, then B5.
Bishop B4, we play B5 and we're chilling.
And that's, of course, something that
you have to see also, which is that
when you eliminate the Pawn, and you
should ask yourself that question,
whenever you eliminate a Pawn or a
piece, you know, what was that Pawn or
piece actually doing?
What was it controlling?
And when you ask yourself that
question, sometimes you, you discover
that, well, certain Pawn breaks or
certain moves are now possible in the
absence of that Pawn or piece.
Okay.
So it's just something that you always
want to get into the habit of doing,
particularly if it's an important Pawn
or piece, one that's in the center, one
that's controlling a lot of squares.
What new resources are possible?
Then anybody should be able to see B5.
Our opponent is exhausting most of his time.
I don't know what for.
I mean, Bishop B8 is largely forced.
What's funny is that if White moves,
no, actually Bishop B4, yeah, B5, we
would have to untangle our pieces
there, but it would not be too
difficult to do that.
The power of simplification.
Yeah.
So Bishop B8, Knight D6, Bishop takes
F7 check, Knight takes F7.
Then White's going to move the Rook
probably up to F3.
And then our next project will be to
coordinate our minor pieces so that
they are actually all working together
and defending each other.
And in that resulting position, what we
would have to prevent is kind of the
Rook infiltration to the seventh rank.
Because Rooks are stronger than minor
pieces when they're able to gain kind
of maximum activity.
Okay.
Bishop B4.
I'm relieved to see that move.
I think it's easier for Black to win in
this position.
So now we play B5.
That's a no brainer.
Intercepting the Bishop.
And now next step for us is to consolidate.
And consolidating, that's a word that a
lot of people misunderstand.
It basically just means you have a
situation where your pieces are kind of
scattered around the board and they're
not well coordinated.
Can we bring those pieces onto good
squares such that they're working
together, et cetera, et cetera.
Now here, there's an interesting moment
because you might notice that the Rook
is X -raying the E4 pawn.
I think a lot of you are probably
thinking, let's go Knight C6.
After Knight C6, the Bishop will drop
back to C3.
And if we take the pawn on E4, I'm a
little bit apprehensive about the move
of Rook to F3 in that position.
And White tries to lift the Rook up to G3.
And this Bishop on C3 is controlling
the retreating square on H8.
If Black can send us, if our opponent
can send us in the direction of F8,
well, maybe that's a little bit, little
bit scary in time pressure.
So let's see if we can find anything safer.
I think there is a safer option, which
is not to play Knight C6, but to play
Knight to G6.
I want a little bit, I want a bodyguard
on the King side just to make sure that
there's no shenanigans that are
awaiting us on the G file.
Does that make sense?
Let's go Knight G6, Rook F3.
Yeah, our opponent was basically
waiting to pre -move that.
I guess we should have played Knight to
C6 because that would have won the Bishop.
Let's think about this for a second.
If we play Rook takes E4, there is the
move Rook F1.
That's a little bit annoying, actually.
That is a little bit annoying, but I
think we have a winning tactic there.
I think we have a winning tactic there.
Yeah, I think we can play Rook E4.
I think we can grab this pawn.
Now, what do I see when we play Rook
takes E4?
Well, what I see, what is the Rook on
E4 doing?
Well, again, X -rays, X -rays, X -rays,
super important.
And here you should see that the Rook
is X -raying the Bishop.
Now, what does that tell us?
Well, that tells us that if we move the
Knight, we'll be attacking the Bishop
on B4.
But it is scary to move the Knight
because it also opens up the line of
fire to the F7 pawn.
So we have to move the Knight on such a
square such that we take the sting out
of the move.
Bishop takes F7.
Check.
Of course, we play Knight E5.
There is a slightly scary option,
though, that I missed.
There must be a way out.
Yeah, there is a way.
There is a way for us to keep our extra piece.
If our opponent does this, then I'll
mention it.
No, Rook F7, I saw.
Rook F7, we play Knight F7.
And basically, we're up a Rook.
Rook F7, Knight F7.
Bishop F7.
00:30:32,520 --> 00:30:32,300
King G7.
Yeah, I allowed this to get complicated.
This was very sloppy by me.
And I think there is a way for White to
make this super complicated.
But this is going to take a little bit
of GM magic.
Yeah, no, this was...
We should have just played Rook D8.
And again, this is the lack of prophylaxis.
I was impatient.
This is a very instructive mistake
because I got impatient.
I wasn't willing to invest exactly two
more moves.
And then there would be no threats.
And we could just proceed and bring the
Bishop back and win the game easily.
No, I had to play Rook E4.
And I missed this.
Knight F7.
We have to trade, take on F7.
And now we bring the King up to G7.
And what I saw was that if Black...
Yeah, crap.
Our opponent found everything here.
Okay.
King H6.
King H6, we have to go there.
And this is where I missed a move.
I calculated up to this point.
I did calculate up to this point.
And the only thing that I saw was
Bishop to D5.
This is what I saw.
And after Bishop to D5, what we
essentially can do is say, okay, we're
going to lose one of our Rooks.
But we can connect the Rooks so that if
White takes the Rook, we take the
Bishop and then we're up a minor piece.
And we're finally essentially home free.
Then we're finally...
I mean, it's still not that easy to
convert because our Bishop is terrible.
But that I think we will be able to win.
We also have B4.
Yeah, B4 is definitely a resource to
keep in mind.
But this is going to get very, very
dicey if White finds the right move here.
Which I won't mention, but not that I'm
suspecting our opponent of anything, of
stream sniping.
Obviously, 100 % not.
Actually, wait a second.
There's a crazy idea.
Oh, my God.
It might actually work.
I need to calculate it.
Wildly difficult to calculate in time pressure.
There is a beautiful idea that we have.
I could have played it on this move.
So the move that I'm scared of that I
didn't see is Bishop back to D2 check.
That's the move I failed to anticipate.
Bishop D2 check.
I only saw Bishop D5.
And then I think we're fine.
Still, it's dicey.
Still, it's dicey in that position, but
I think we'll be able to win.
But the move that I missed was Bishop
D2 check.
Why is it so scary?
Because King h5 is terrifying in that position.
We could get mated there.
Rook f5 check.
Maybe it's mate, maybe it's not, but
it's scary.
So after Bishop D2 check, if we go back
to G7, White just keeps repeating moves.
Bishop D2, Bishop c3.
And we can't go back to f8.
That's another big problem because then
we walk right into a discovered attack
and White wins all of our pieces.
There is an idea.
Okay.
Yeah.
Let me think.
Okay.
Well, let's repeat moves once.
That's not going to hurt.
It's definitely not going to hurt.
Okay.
I think I might've figured out a
brilliant win, but it hinges on
basically move for move calculation.
So if I'm wrong, we're worse.
Okay.
I don't know what our opponent is
thinking about because Bishop c3 is
absolutely forced.
Bishop c3 is absolutely forced.
And then my idea is to play knight e5,
which itself is not a surprising move
for people.
I think.
Knight e5.
But after Bishop d5, I think we might
have a crazy resource.
Let's give it a shot.
Knight e5.
So knight e5 is a logical move, but it
seems to fail to Bishop d5.
And it appears that we're losing the
game there because we're losing all of
our pieces after Bishop d5, but there,
I think I found a resource that
involves identifying the x -ray against
the white Rook on f1 and playing what
move, what am I, what do I have my eye
on here?
Yeah.
B4, which leads to absolute chaos
because now both, everything is hanging.
Everything except the Bishop on d5 is
now hanging.
Oh, he found Rook f7, but wait a second.
Rook f7 is not scary, I think, because
we have to go up to, where do we go with?
Let me think about this.
We have to go to g6, I think.
King g6 is the critical move.
Yeah.
I saw this.
King g6.
And if white takes on e4, okay, wait,
there's no way this move works.
Or does it?
Oh my God.
What is happening here?
Wait a second.
No.
I don't think this works because I
think we can just play bc.
No, it's still complicated there.
Or can we play Knight f3 check?
Can we play Knight f3 check?
Gf3, Rook e6, yeah, Knight f3 wins.
Knight f3 just wins the game.
And I did, I almost didn't see this move.
It comes out of nowhere.
You wouldn't think that there's like a
discovery against White's King that
ends the game, but there is.
Well, the positive news is that we will
have some very exciting analysis to do.
This is going to be really fun.
Yeah.
Knight f3 check wins because Pawn takes f3.
Everybody should be able to calculate
the resulting line.
We play Rook takes e7, White takes the
Rook on a8, we take the Bishop on c3,
and we are up a full Rook in that
resulting position.
Okay.
Not a hard line to calculate.
The moment, and how did I see it?
Well, because I looked at the position
with kind of a fresh pair of eyes.
I'll tell you what I was fixated on before.
The moment I took a step back and like
asked myself, can I make any other
observations, like do, can I see
anything else interesting about this position?
That's the moment I spotted that there
is a connection, a standoff between the Rooks.
This is the importance of taking the
broader perspective.
I can see according to the engine that
bc is also winning, but it's a lot less convincing.
Okay.
So I propose that we start, let's start
from the start and let's be patient.
I want to look at the opening first and
then we will get to the end game pretty quickly.
I won't take too long on the opening,
but this is an opening related speed run.
So I want to do at least a little bit
of theoretical analysis every game.
All right.
So I'm going to pull up chess base and
a Grand Prix has given me some problems.
The Grand Prix attack, I think is one
of the best anti Sicilians along with
the Gallopin.
And I, I think a lot of title players
and a lot of good players just don't
really study it that, that seriously,
even though it's, you know, it is a
very serious opening.
It is a very serious opening.
So e4 c5, knight c3, you play g6.
Now we have played this move once
before, and I distinctly remember in
that speed run, we talked about a move
that tries to essentially exploit the
drawback of the move g6.
What is a move that white has, which
tries to specifically capitalize on the
fact that black hasn't gone knight c6.
And this may seem like a very scary
move, but we analyzed it and it's not
bad for black.
Yeah.
So d4, right?
And after cd, queen d4, if I mean,
clearly you're punished for the knight
not being on c6 and we analyze this
line knight f6.
And if white plays e5, this is very
important to remember black plays
knight c6 with tempo.
This is the critical resource and black
is okay here.
I remember us analyzing this position.
So instead of e5, white is best advised
to play, you know, knight f3 or
something like that.
But black is doing fine here.
This is essentially a dragon like position.
This is a dragon like position where
white is slightly better according to
the engine.
I think Duda Carlson had this.
I won't analyze this again.
You can find this in the previous video
where we had this line in the game,
white plays the grand pre -attack f4.
So bishop g7, knight f3, knight c6
here, white is at a further crossroads.
As far as I remember, there is bishop
b5, which we've already faced in this game.
We faced the old school move, which is
still very, very dangerous.
Bishop c4.
So let's see what the top guys actually
do here.
Let's see what the best way for black
to handle this actually is, because I
don't think it's the way that I played.
Okay.
So according to the engine, e6 and d6
are both legitimate moves.
So we can go with d6 for now.
And if we don't like what we see, we
can take a look at e6.
So d6, castles, e6, computer gives
equality, tiny edge for black, which it
always does in the grand pre -attack and
white plays this very risky, but very
dangerous move, d4.
So here we responded correctly.
The move is c takes d4.
White plays knight to b5.
Black plays knight g to e7.
And according to the engine, at least
at a lower depth, the computer actually
does like the move a6, but it also
likes knight g7.
It gives equality here.
Bishop to b3 is correct.
So this is theory and castles is correct.
Knight b takes d4.
Knight a5 is the top move.
Okay.
So I can improvise on my feet.
This is the top engine line with knight a5.
And it's along with a couple of other
lines, which the computer assigns as
equals 0 .00.
There are still games in the database.
There are still games in the database,
23 games, including some grandmaster
games after bishop b3.
Now we played b6 still games in the
database, but b6 it likes a little bit less.
It still gives it as equal.
Okay.
So I think b6 is normal and c4 is not a novelty.
It was played in 2022 by a grandmaster
Lars Oscar Hauga against another
grandmaster in a tournament in Iceland.
It was played by two Icelandic grandmasters.
So clearly this is still preparation
and bishop a6 was played in that game.
Oh my God.
Bishop basics was played and our
opponent played the best move f5 is an
improvement is an improvement over the
move that was played in the game, which
is night to be five.
This was played in the grandmaster game.
And I'd be five is a very serious mistake.
It's a blunder.
Can anybody tell me why night b5 is a blunder?
Our opponent, I mean, absolute kudos.
He knew everything here.
He knew this very, very deeply.
Why is night b5 a horrible blunder?
And black responded correctly in the
game, but lost the game.
Actually black lost the game, but
responded correctly.
It's already minus two.
Yeah.
D five simply, simply D five.
And this night is in huge trouble.
I mean, the C four pawn gets undermined
in the game.
White played Queenie too.
And here D takes C four was played, but
that's a big mistake.
Apparently, according to the engine,
you're supposed to trade everything and
then play D four, trade everything and
then win the pawn.
And if white plays night to G five,
black has even Queen to D three is
very, very strong.
And obviously this is a disaster.
So this is not acceptable for white and
our opponent improving on the game and
F five gives white a pretty big
advantage according to the engine.
So Bishop a six is actually the first
mistake of the game.
Everything up to that point was normal.
What black is supposed to do here is in
fact, go Bishop to B seven.
And the difference is that after F
five, you're supposed to go E F five E
F five.
And now you justify the placement of
the Bishop by striking in the center
with D five.
This is the point of locating the
Bishop on B seven.
Now we will check why the same thing is
not as applicable with the Bishop on a six.
That's called the method of comparison.
That's where you really get to the
bottom of why the engine recommends
what it does.
But first let's have a look at this
very complicated position.
So what moves would you play here with white?
I want to see what the chat thinks
white should do here.
What are some moves that we should look
at here from black's perspective?
Yeah.
Bishop G five is my instinct.
Bishop G five is my instinct because it
threatens F six.
That's a nasty move.
I also think we should look at CD.
I don't like CD.
I think CD is bad for white.
Yeah, it is bad for white because you
take the Bishop and opening up the
center favors the side with the better bishops.
In this case, it's black.
And after a takes B three, Knight takes
D five.
I mean, obviously black is totally fine here.
Bishop G five and simply Knight F six.
And black is black is home free.
So white doesn't want to take that pawn.
That would be very short sighted.
Instead, Bishop to G five is one of the
top engine moves and black has to find
an only move here.
Queen up to D six.
Obvious move to prevent F six.
You have to prevent F six.
The funny thing is if instead you try
to take the Bishop first white plays F
six anyway, this is the reason you have
to go Queen D six and white threatens
to take both of these pieces.
So apparently you have to go Queen D six.
Knight to B five is not scary because
black has a check on C five.
Super important detail.
The engine line is crazy.
Queen to E one attacking the Knight again.
Now black has several moves, but one of
them is to take on D four.
Holy smokes.
Why would you give up the dark squared Bishop?
Who can find the right follow -up here?
Like you almost never do this in the Sicilian.
The only reason you do this is if you
have something incredibly concrete.
If you have a specific tactic, then you
take on D four.
Who can spot the follow -up move?
No, the follow -up has to be something specific.
It can't just be rookie aid.
Then why did you give up your Bishop?
Right?
It has to be something concrete.
It is D take C because the Knight on D
four is undefended.
The Knight on D four is undefended
because the point is if white plays
Bishop B seven, then you play Queen
takes D four check, and then you can
take the other Bishop.
So white has to defend this Knight at
all costs with rook to D one.
Now this is crazy.
Now you play F six.
It's equal 0 .00 Bishop F four, only
move Queen D five only move threatening checkmate.
Rook F two only move defending against mate.
Take the Bishop 96.
Line is still continuing and it's only
moves for both sides here.
This is engine analysis.
Queen E four, rookie two only moves.
Every other move would lead to an
advantage for either side.
Queen F five, Knight F eight, Knight D
five only move.
Bishop D six, Knight C four, Queen H
four only move.
It's leading to a draw.
Just you wait.
Takes Queen H seven and it's a
perpetual check, check, check, check
because the King can't cross the E file.
This is the Sicilian ladies and gentlemen.
And, and this is why people are asking,
why is it hard to make a course on the
Sicilian or a course in general?
I mean, this is the reason because of
lines like this.
This is a ridiculous engine line and it
all starts.
It's normal until Bishop takes D four.
This is what causes the pandemonium.
Now black has alternatives here to
Bishop takes D four.
There is the more conventional move
Rook A eight, although the position is
no less crazy because here the line
goes Knight B five Queen C five check
Bishop B three.
Now another ridiculous engine move.
Knight takes up five, giving up the
Queen capturing the Queen, but giving
up an exchange.
Apparently black has full compensation
for the exchange here because your
Bishop is a beast and because you have
a pawn C D five you take the Bishop and
then you take the pawn and this is
equal because the Bishops are really
crisscrossing the board and offer black
sufficient compensation.
So in a game I would play Bishop D four
cause that's too sexy of a move not to play.
So that is the simple reason why Bishop
B seven is the best move in the position.
Yeah.
I mean who, I don't even really think I
had to show this.
This is, this is basic Betty right
here, but it's amazing to me that our
opponents, knowledge of this opening
extended past theory, like C four one
game in the database, recent game.
So this was clearly White's preparation
and he improved on the play of a GM.
So now let's understand what the
difference is after Bishop basics at five.
And the question that you want to ask
yourself is this, what happens if black
plays in exactly the same way that you
would after Bishop B seven?
That's how you get to the bottom of why
a certain move is better than another one.
So the question is after EF EF, why
can't we play the move D five?
Like what's the actual reason?
So apparently according to the engine,
the reason consists in the move Knight
to G five.
This is the reputation.
Now you might say, well, wait a second.
Well, why wasn't Knight G five a thing
after Bishop B seven?
Does that process make sense?
So let's look at Knight G five here and
then we'll look at it with the Bishop
on a six and eventually we're going to
understand what the critical difference is.
If you play Knight G five here, black
plays DC.
So now we go back to the other line.
Now we go back to the other line and
we, we, we, we check DC here.
Um, we check DC here.
So if DC here, then black white plays F
G and if black plays H G, then Queen G
four leads to checkmate.
Now we go back to the other line.
Why is F G not good there?
So Knight G five DC F G I hope what I'm
doing actually like makes sense.
We're just comparing the placement of,
ah, and this is the point where black
has an additional resource.
See it's pretty easy if you know the
process to follow.
Now who can tell me, let's see if
anybody can use logic to figure this out.
What could possibly be the virtue of
having the Bishop on B seven?
What could possibly be an additional
resource that solves black's problems here?
Yeah, it's Queen D five.
It's Queen D five.
Because the only thing you can do with
that Bishop is threatened checkmate.
And apparently this move allows black
to throw a spanner in the works.
White is unable to attack properly
because of the mate threat.
If white goes here, then you go H five,
just deflecting the Queen.
If G F you can of course take with the
Rook because the Queen is hanging and
if the Queen moves back, then you can
just play Bishop takes D four G F seven.
You still play Rook F seven.
Holy fricking smokes.
And after Rook F seven, you again use
the fact that the Queen is tied down to
G two and you take all of white's pieces.
You just take everything and you're
going to take a fourth minor piece on
the next move, which is also hanging.
And so that is the critical difference.
With the Bishop on A six, with the
Bishop on A six, you don't have this
resource of Queen D five here.
So what you ultimately have to do is
play either H G and lose after Queen to
G four, because this is unstoppable.
Or if you take the Bishop on B three,
then you lose the game after Queen H five.
Yeah.
White, this is just overwhelming attack here.
H six is forced G F here.
Oh, Oh, there's a sexy move here again.
Rook F six threatening Rook takes H six
with checkmate in two moves.
Black has to go Knight G eight.
And now just Rook G six.
This is just absolutely crushing.
F G is coming and there's too many mate
threats here.
And that's it.
Knight G five is the big reason that
you want to play the move Bishop to B seven.
And that's the takeaway from the
opening in this game.
Hope you enjoyed that little excursion
into the depths of Sicilian nonsense.
Now, by the way, I should point out for
the sake of completeness that after the
move B six, after the move B six,
White's main move, like the most
popular move has been Queen to E one,
because you're trying to get the Queen
around to H four, but this is bad
because of Bishop A six, this is a bad move.
And the problem, this was a game
between a 2 ,400 and a 2 ,586 classical game.
White has to play Rook F two.
And then it begs the question, well,
then why did you put the Queen on E one?
If you can't even get it to H four.
And Black is better after Knight B
three, A B three and Bishop B seven.
And Black is, White is experiencing
serious problems with the E four pawn.
This is the game Wang against Zhao,
Washington, 2022 in that game White
played out five and Black responded
cold bloodedly with E five.
White played Bishop G five, which is an
idea that we actually had in the game.
Interesting.
And here Black responds with H six.
This is actually how the game continued.
F six, H G, F G, King G seven.
And here White found a sick tactic, but
it doesn't work.
Knight G five, E takes D four, Rook
takes F seven check.
And who can tell me how should Black
respond to this move?
What should Black do?
Let's see if you understand the concept
of Queen disease properly.
This is such a common type of mistake
that people make.
So a lot of people's automatic reaction
would be, well, I can't take the Rook
because I lose my Queen, but you have
to always put it in context.
How would, how would, how much are you
getting for the Queen?
Everybody forgets to ask this question.
You actually do want to take the Rook.
And after 96 King G, 98 Rook D eight,
Black gets a crap ton of material for
the Queen.
You get two minor pieces in a Rook.
Yeah.
White gets another pawn on a seven
true, but we can chew the Rook away
with Knight C six.
And White also has this major weakness
on E four, which you can really zero in
on with Rook E eight.
Black is much better slash winning.
This is how the game continued actually.
So Black was able to win the game in
this way.
So C four is an improvement over Queen
E one and over a couple of other moves
that was played in this position.
I also see that Queen D three was
played, but this doesn't seem all that scary.
So let's get to the game.
F five.
We decided to play E five.
The question is where did our opponent
actually end up going wrong?
Our opponent ended up going wrong in
this position.
Knight B five is an automatic move.
And after Knight B five, already Black
is doing all right.
It's equal, but with the best move,
White is plus over minus.
And I saw the best move.
I missed it initially.
I saw it ultimately.
What is the best move for White?
Same idea that we just saw.
You have to understand how vulnerable
these two minor pieces are and you have
to set up the move F six.
How do you do that?
Bishop G five.
Bishop G five is best.
Now a couple of very important details.
If Black plays F six, then White has 96.
So that fails.
If Black takes the Knight, then F six
is devastating.
And you might say, well, I don't get
why F six is so devastating.
Like we just won a piece.
White's winning a piece back.
What's the big deal?
The problem isn't that White is winning
the piece back.
It's which piece he's winning.
The problem is we cannot keep this
Bishop and you should understand
intuitively why without this Bishop.
There are some exceptions.
We saw an exception, but in most cases
you cannot survive without this Bishop.
If you play Bishop F six, I mean, look
at this position.
Queen D two, Queen H six is literally unstoppable.
Literally.
So that's lost.
And you can't keep the Bishop because
White plays F E and wins the Rook.
So that's the actual reason this move
is so scary.
Now Black should respond here with H
six and force the Bishop away.
And here White plays Bishop H four G five.
And let's see if people can once again,
find a move that's very much in the
spirit of the Grand Prix attack.
This leads to a crazy line that I think
you guys will really enjoy.
But what's the move here?
Because two pieces are hanging.
So you might think it's Knight takes G
five because that's what you're used to.
But think for a second about what piece
you want to leave on the board.
Yeah.
The move is Bishop G five compare, right?
When you compare this position to this
position, which attacker is stronger?
If you ask yourself that question,
well, clearly this Knight is the
stronger attacker because it combines
with the Queen and here Black has to
find an only move, which is ridiculous,
impossible move.
If Black takes, then this is obviously checkmate.
This is obviously checkmate.
Rookie eight, you take this pawn, you
go back.
This is easy.
Check.
And then at the end you have mate with 96.
This is pretty elementary patterns.
Black has to find Knight D five.
And the logic of this move is straightforward.
You're trying to eliminate the Knight
on G five.
But why are you putting the Knight on D five?
Well, there's a secondary reason, which
is that if White plays Queen H five,
then the Knight is able to drop back to
F six and protect H seven.
That's why you don't go Knight C six or
Knight C eight or any other Knight move.
So after 95 White finds a counter blow
Knight D E six, Jesus F takes C six
Knight takes C six and White just gets
a huge attack.
Queen F six.
And now apparently after Queen takes D
five, it's plus over equals.
It's like 0 .6.
Finally, the smoke clears.
Black plays Bishop B seven to force the
Queen away.
Queen to D three and White has
overwhelming compensation for the piece.
There's the idea of Rook F three, Rook
G three.
The Knight is a monster.
And at this point, White already has
three pawns for the piece.
Just mind blowing complications with
Bishop G five.
But this would have caught put us in
very serious trouble.
This would have put us in very serious trouble.
Yeah.
This is why chess is, chess is so fun.
I hope I'm not going too deep, but this
is how you learn about tactics, right?
It's not just solving puzzles.
Analyzing helps you really just get to
the bottom of some of these ideas.
And it's also fun.
It's fun to analyze with an engine.
It's also fun when you have a
grandmaster like guiding you around,
which is what I'm trying to do.
So after E five Knight B five, now
we're able to take this pawn and now
black is fine.
Now black is fine.
So our opponent correctly plays Knight
takes D six.
Finally, the smoke clears and here 95
is the horrible move.
Our opponent is trying to play in the
spirit of the grand Prix attack, but he
just doesn't have enough going on the
King side to justify this pawns.
This Knight sack, this, this Knight
sack is just terrible.
The correct move is Bishop F two.
And according to the engine, the move
that I intended to play was best Queen
C seven in order to be able to play
Rook a D eight.
And here we were calculating Knight G five.
I was mentioning this during the game.
Black has to play H six.
Why does black have to play H six?
Because if you procrastinate, then this
is devastating because the maid is
threatened and now Knight F seven is horrendous.
So here you have to immediately root
out the Knight.
Knight takes F seven, Rook F seven and
F seven King F seven.
What should white play here?
Who can tell me, how should white proceed?
Continue the initiative.
Otherwise white is much worse.
This is like, this is a no brainer.
This move should be automatic to you.
Yeah.
C five.
Very nice.
C five black takes the Bishop, but the
Queen replaces the Bishop and the
benefit of the Queen on B three.
Once the King escapes is that white can
play CB a B and maybe white could grab
that pawn or white could just move the
Rook away.
And the engine gives equality here,
which I agree with.
I think it's just a super complicated
position that's hard to evaluate.
And usually that means equal.
So this is how the game.
Should have continued, but our opponent
just is unable to maintain the tension.
He plays Knight takes e5.
And now let's get directly to the final
stage of the game.
Because after Bishop e5 and Queen takes
d6, Black is winning.
Black is winning.
This is up a piece.
And I just wanted to point out before
we get to the final stage of the game,
where you saw this before.
So where you saw this before, and I
just realized we played this guy once before.
This is the second time we played this guy.
Oh, it was the Jebaba London game where
I missed knight e4.
So no wonder we got into a bad position here.
I was in trouble as well.
So this guy, this guy knows what he's doing.
I'm just looking for the game.
Yeah, this is the game where you saw a
very similar tactic.
Remember that when a piece is defended
by another piece, particularly if it's
a Rook or a Queen, you can generally
chase away the defender.
So remember this game, where we first
played Knight g7, and then we did the
same thing with the Bishop.
This is exactly what our opponent did.
Attack the Rook.
That's exactly what we did.
And if the Rook has to move, then you
take the Knight.
Now compared to this game, we had an
additional resource in this position,
which is of course Knight takes e4.
And if Bishop e8, then we play Knight d6.
And the Rook is hanging.
The Bishop is hanging.
I explained this during the game.
Black is winning.
So let's go to the game.
Bishop b4, b5, Bishop b3, Knight g6,
Rook f3.
And Rook takes e4 is probably not a
mistake in itself.
But I think the safer move, the safer
move would have been just to bring
another Rook into the game.
Just defend the f7 pawn.
And White is out of ideas.
White is simply out of ideas.
Our next move is going to be either
Rook takes e4 or Bishop b7.
We're going to win the e4 pawn.
We're going to win the game.
So remember the power of prophylaxis.
When you stop your opponent's threats,
it's so much easier to play.
I could not resist because I thought
that I had calculated this accurately.
And it turns out that this is a lot
more complicated than I made it out to be.
So what happens if White plays Bishop f7?
Well, this is easy.
This is easy.
You take the Bishop and then you take
the other Bishop and you're up two
minor pieces.
But of course our opponent finds
something fancier than that.
Rook takes f7.
And this move is a lot scarier because
if you ignore the Rook, then you lose
the game to Rook takes a7 check.
And White will take this Rook with
check and then win the Bishop as well.
So our hand is forced here.
We have to play Knight f7, Rook f7,
Bishop f7, King g7.
And now the second important moment, okay?
Now in this position, White actually
had another very interesting resource,
which was the move Rook takes f7.
And in order to preserve an advantage,
Black has to find an only move in this position.
This is a very difficult move.
So if you're watching on YouTube, I
highly recommend that you pause the
video and try to figure out the defense here.
Because it's very easy to blunder here.
There's a mupwa, most popular wrong answer.
So the most popular wrong answer is
Rook takes Bishop because you might
say, aha, well, what is White going to do?
Well, probably White is going to try to
win the most number of pieces, right?
So White's going to take on a7.
But I saw one step ahead, I'm going to
take the Bishop and I'm going to win.
No, you're not.
White takes the Rook with check and
then takes the other Rook.
And if you don't take the Bishop and
you move the King, you have to stay on
the 8th rank.
And the problem is that you also lose
the Bishop on a6 in the end.
Does that make sense?
So if you instead move the King to the
side, this also is not going to cut it
because White's going to give you this
nasty little check on c3.
And yeah, you can block with knight e5,
but just look at this position.
This is a disaster.
Everything is being lost right now.
Or White could play Rook e7 and pick up
the Knight.
You're going to lose the game here.
So the correct idea is Rook to c4,
cutting off, slicing off the discovered attack.
This is the benefit of being up a Rook.
You get to give away some of your material.
And here Black is winning.
Black is up a piece.
Now according to the engine, White
preserves some practical chances with
Rook c7 because Black's King is so bad
and Black's minor pieces are so bad
that it's really, really hard to untangle.
And here the best move is just to bring
the Bishop around to the center.
Bishop c8 is a really strong move.
And okay, Black will have to
demonstrate some technique, but this is winning.
This is winning.
Does that make sense?
So instead our opponent plays Bishop f7.
We have to go up.
Bishop c3.
King h6.
And Bishop d2 is the move that I missed.
And according to the, according to the
engine, I had no idea whether we were
winning or losing after King h5.
Apparently Black is still better, but
can you really blame me for not wanting
to go for this position?
I mean, this is crazy.
This is crazy.
Let me run Stockfish here at a high
depth and give you the best line.
Stockfish at a high depth.
This is where the Chess .com engine
really is insufficient.
Positions that are this complicated
need to be looked at with a serious engine.
So apparently, here's the evaluation.
Just a second.
The evaluation is an advantage.
No, it's equal.
Oh my God.
But this is insane.
This is impossible.
Apparently the best move here is not to
give this check, but instead to play
Bishop d5.
So just to make sure we're on the same
page, how should Black respond to this move?
How should Black respond to Bishop d5?
Just to make sure everybody understand
what's going on here.
Yeah, Rook ae8, right?
Rook ae8.
Now there is an only move.
If anybody finds this move in a game,
you immediately call the TD or you call
Danny Wrench.
Literally.
Apparently the best move, there is a
move that keeps equality, which is just
to take and go Rook f7 and win all of
Black's pawns.
But the absolute best move is h3.
H3.
And the idea is to take away the g4
square from Black's king.
That's the idea.
So if Black moves the Rook, then
there's checkmate in three moves.
Check, check, mate.
That's the idea.
Black's king is caught in something
like a mating net here.
And Black can draw with King h4.
And now White plays Bishop e4, Rook e4,
Rook f5.
Black's king is still in serious trouble.
But there is a perpetual check.
King g3, check, King h4, and we have a
repetition of moves.
Black can't do anything else here.
Because if instead you play a move like
Bishop c8, you get checkmated.
Check.
And this is the secondary idea of h3.
Now White has g4.
And you have to give up your Rook.
And if you go the other way, you get checkmated.
So yeah.
So it was a good call for me not to go
King h5.
In long story short.
So I decided to apply the final idea,
knight e5.
And without this idea, this game would
have been a draw.
Because without this move, and I played
correctly, apparently this is still equal.
But White has to be super precise.
So let me tell you what I calculated
with this move, knight e5.
Oh my gosh.
I calculated the...
Oh!
Okay.
This is...
This is amazing.
You're going to enjoy this tremendously.
This is beautiful.
Okay.
Get ready.
So.
Okay.
First of all, let's make sure we're all
on the same page.
What is the point of knight e5?
Well, the point is that the King has
nowhere to go.
Because if you go back to f8, you get
massacred with Bishop d5, or Bishop g6
even better.
We've already discussed why King h6 and
King h5 doesn't work.
So I figured the only other idea is to
block with the knight.
If you try blocking with the rook
instead, this is a very ingenious idea.
The problem is that White's going to
take the knight first, and then take
the rook.
Okay?
So here White plays Bishop d5, and
everything hinges on this move b4,
which thrusts the game into complete
and total chaos.
And here, I had to calculate a certain
line that at first sight may seem to be
only beneficial to White.
What are the possibilities here for White?
Our opponent lost the game quickly with
rook f7, that was a mistake.
What should White do instead?
Which pieces should White take?
Well basically, White has three
candidate moves, okay?
What are White's three candidate moves?
There's Bishop takes knight, there's
Bishop takes rook, and there's Bishop
takes other rook.
Bishop takes knight is really dumb.
Because you just take.
And at the end, White is down an exchange.
Okay?
So that's ruled out.
Which rook should White take?
Well, White should actually take this rook.
Because if you take the other rook,
Black's going to take the bishop.
Why is Black going to take the bishop?
Black is not going to take the rook
here, because that allows Bishop takes
e5 check.
So we're going to take the bishop,
White's going to take the rook, we're
going to take the rook, and at the end,
the bishop on a8 is terribly placed.
King takes f1, loses the game to c2.
Compare that to the other capture.
Bishop takes a8, same thing happens.
bc, Bishop e4, Bishop f1, King f1.
Here the bishop is optimally placed,
because c2 is impossible.
But I saw this, and I thought that
Black is winning here with c takes b2.
Now how do we assess this position?
Well, what does Black want?
Black wants to get the knight over to
a3, and promote the pawn and win a piece.
And it turns out that White's king is
not fast enough.
Because White plays King e2, that's not
the beautiful part.
All of this I saw, all of this I saw.
And look at this position, King d1,
knight e3.
And you're preventing the king from
stopping the pawn on the next move
Black promotes to a queen, and some
technique is required, but Black is in
fact winning here.
That line makes sense to everybody.
This line.
But here's the beautiful part.
After King e2, knight c4, White has an
only drawing move.
Incredible idea.
I've never seen quite this idea before.
White to play and draw the game.
Again, if you're watching on YouTube, I
really think you should set this up and
take some time on this, because this is
a high level exercise.
So stronger players watching, you
really would want to take some time on it.
Yeah, one of you got it.
Well, bishop b1 doesn't help, right?
Bishop b1 doesn't do anything.
It just makes it worse, because now I
make this move with tempo.
If you play bishop c2 and King d3, I'm
not going to take your bishop.
I'm just going to promote.
But hopefully you're spotting a
pattern, which is your basic...
How do you solve this?
Well, the basic premise, the basic idea
is that in the situation after Black
takes on b1, the knight is essentially trapped.
And if you keep calculating here, you
might find that King c2 almost traps
the knight.
Here the knight is able to escape, but
only through b5.
That's the only square that the knight
is able to escape through.
Otherwise, you would have to repeat
moves forever.
Knight b1, King c2, etc.
So it's a prophylactic move that sets
up the drawing mechanism.
a4 is correct.
a4.
Knight a3.
Now you walk the king over.
Black promotes.
You trade.
And with b5 under your control, you're
able to force a repetition of moves.
King b3.
And knight doesn't have b5.
Knight has to go back to b1.
Now not King b2, because then the
knight escapes.
King c2 to keep the knight confined.
And this is a draw.
And that's how I could have drawn the game.
Unbelievable.
So the line is in this position, Bishop
a8, bc, Bishop e4.
This is the easy part.
King e2 or a4, by the way, a4 even here
is good.
Doesn't matter what the order is.
But you can't forget to play a4,
because otherwise the knight sits on a3
and your pawn is in immobilized.
This is brilliant.
a8, 4.
Drawing move.
This absolutely should be used.
I'll use this in some video, because
I'll eventually do a book or a
chessable course like best moments from
speedrun series, most instructive
moments, and this is one of them.
This is unbelievable.
I'd be one king c2.
I hope you found this as beautiful as I did.
So Bishop a8 could have drawn the game,
but instead our opponent gives this
tempting check.
And now the problem is that if white
tries to do the same thing, right, if
white plays Bishop takes a8 now, well,
it's not going to work anymore, because
at the end of this line, what's the difference?
Well, the difference is the bishop used
to be on f1.
Here black is not making us be the one
to take the rook with the king.
With the bishop, instead we're taking
the rook with the king, and white loses.
So our opponent tried this move, but we
win the game immediately with knight f3.
Probably the most resilient would have
been to play Bishop takes e4 check and
Bishop takes e5.
This would have kept white in the game,
because here white has a pawn for the
exchange, but black is still winning.
Black is still winning.
Not a piece.
We are not winning a piece because of
this check, but black should win this
with technique, because the center is
wide open, and the rook should prevail
in this case.
So this would have been the best chance
for black, for white, but still, okay,
we can't blame our opponent for
collapsing with the rook e7.
I almost missed knight f3 check.
That's an easy move to forget about.
And that, ladies and gentlemen, is one
of the most complicated games that we
have played.
I had a feeling that we were going to
get something good, and we did.
So in conclusion, g6 is a good move
against knight c3 if you're an
accelerated player.
Then everything here was correct.
We followed theory.
Now if you're a theory junkie, you can
investigate e6 on your own.
I'm not going to do that in this video,
just because I want to keep things at a
normal length.
The way we played was fine.
Our opponent played this very dangerous
modern line with d4.
We responded to it correctly by
developing our pieces.
Bishop b3, by the way, is a nice move.
And the idea is to take the sting out
of the move d5, prophylaxis.
We responded correctly with knight a5
and b6, and this is still theory.
This was our mistake, bishop a6.
So the improvement is bishop b7.
Then the improvement for our opponent
would have been to play bishop g5.
And then, of course, the situation
remained very complicated.
He gave up a piece here.
Bishop f2 would have kept an unclear position.
And then, fast forward all the way to
the end, the beautiful draw with bishop
takes a8 after b4.
Any questions?
Okay.
You have said g6 and e6 is wrong.
Why not now?
So great question.
In previous speedruns, I have claimed
that in the Sicilian, you normally
don't want to combine the moves g6 and e6.
That is true.
I have claimed that.
But there is a major caveat, which is
that, okay, positionally, it's quite
dubious to combine g6 and e6.
But normally, it all relates to whether
or not your opponent can gain control
of the d6 square.
In this position, the d6 square is
under black's control.
All right?
The d6 square is under black's control.
But I could also show you a situation
where black plays g6 and e6, and white
is able to stick a queen on d6, or a
knight on d6, or white is able to play
e4, e5, and really clamp down on that square.
That's when you want to be very careful
about combining these two moves.
Here's an example of a game of mine.
I've shown this game many times.
But I think it's the best illustration
of when not to play e6 and g6.
This will hopefully give you a little
context on the difference between this
game and situation where it's bad to
combine these two moves.
Old game of mine.
I managed to win this game.
But look at what happens.
My opponent plays a smith mora.
I made the mistake of taking.
At that point, I had no idea what the
theory was.
So I decided to play g6.
And here, I decided to make a genius
move and play e6.
So what is the chief difference between
this version and the version that we
had in our game?
Well, look at the fact that white has a
direct line of fire to the d6 square.
So he could have played queen d6
immediately, but instead he starts with
knight b5, and that's it.
Already, d6 is under white's complete control.
But instead of giving the check on d6,
which a lot of people would have done,
he plays queen to d6, which wins the
game, because knight c7 is literally unstoppable.
You can't do anything about that move.
I had to play queen e7, and I ended up
losing a full rook.
I win this game because I ultimately
end up winning the knight back, and I
also grabbed this pawn in the center.
So it's not that easy to convert, but
you get the point.
You get the point.
It's all about whether the center is open.
Also, you have to be very careful in a
situation where white is able to play
the move e5 and clamp down on the d6 square.
Let me show you one more example of a
very famous game.
The end of this game is very famous.
The beginning, not as famous, but still
very instructive.
We won't look at the whole game.
I'll just show you the mistake that
black makes early on.
Okay, here it is.
So this is a Petrosian -Pacman game,
which ends with a famous queen sacrifice.
Somewhat overrated combination to end
this game, but here's what Pacman does
wrong in the opening.
Not David.
Ludek.
So basically, here Pacman plays d6 and
e6, which is fine, but then he forgets
to play d6.
Here you have to play d6.
He forgets to do it, and what does
Petrosian do?
What does Petrosian do?
How does he punish Pacman for not
playing d6?
He basically clamps down on the dark squares.
Yeah, he plays e5.
And it's not such a big issue.
Black plays d6, but this resulting
position is terrible because now black
is like, black's structure is worse,
and white's knight is coming to e4, and
this pawn is weak, and the bishop is bad.
So it would have been much, much better
just to avoid all of this by playing d6.
Those are a couple of examples of when
black paid the price for playing these
two moves.
Yeah, this was a bad game for black.
And that's that.
We're going to conclude here.
Thank you for watching.
If you are on YouTube.